he'll face brady singer who will make
his ninth start of the year
he's gone 38 and a third innings of work
allowed 15 walks and 40 strikeouts he's
been consistent but he is still
evolving in this really his sophomore
year look at that wow
beautiful slider at 87 miles an hour
strikes him out
singer throwing machine looks pretty
sharp early matthew making his ninth
start of the year he's faced kansas city
more times than any other team 24 times
in his career
salvi muscles one into left center field
merrifield had to hold for a moment
and they will hold him at third base he
had to freeze to make sure shortstop
castro did not catch the baseball boyd
hasn't given up a run in the first
inning all season well the royals have a
pretty good chance with them loaded here
even if solaire does ground into a
double play they're going to get a run
but
solaire he wants to
stay in his shoes and don't come out of
them by swinging
popped it up boy there's a gift
[Applause]
jonathan scope on the infield infield
fly rule called one away so now it's
been intending
and the royals obviously in this spot
must avoid a double play
base hit left field
and comes merrifield santana right
behind it's two-nothing royals
ben and tendy picking up
jorge solera on that one that was really
nice you know and here's
again ben attendee not trying to do too
much he knows he's gonna wait for the
breaking ball he's gonna get it and it's
outside why not hit it over there that
gives a huge hole
nicely done
ben attendee with his 13th and 14th rbis
[Applause]
struck him out
two away
first time he threw two change up in the
same at bat and he really added and
subtracted as far as speed there you see
that circle change and he spots it down
and away just a really good pitch there
one two to taylor
swung on and missed
but kansas city scores a couple of runs
two and two on mazzara singer brings it
home and strike three call
got the fastball in a really good spot
it was on the inside edge mazara could
not pull the trigger and that strikeout
number two for brady singer ramos at the
plate the payoff to ramos
he laid off it and he draws a walk to
load him up well what an opportunity for
akil badu we know this kid's got some
power potential now the o2
muscles it the other way that's a fair
ball one run is home another runs
trotting home
and he's evened it up akeel badou on an
02 pitch
squeezes it inside the third base bag
and ties it up
and he just tries to throw the barrel of
it got rewarded by beating gutierrez
down the line there
and then it's gonna die and two runs are
allowed to come
around and the 2-2
swing and a miss on a slider away so
brady singer has a 1-2-3 top of the
third
he has struck out three and at the end
of two and a half it's the royals two
and the tigers two matthew boyd trying
to settle in the o2
he went
he did go
third strikeout of the night for matthew
boyd went away here in the third the 2-2
got him he absolutely froze him with a
slider in the middle of the plate
gutierrez will lead things off
oh that ball struck well
that'll get to the fence
played well by grossman
but gutierrez has his first extra base
hit
as a royal in
2021. that's a guy up there looking for
a pitch to hit he's aggressive
sidearm little slider it was up he
recognized it it was elevated all
hitters at this level recognize
elevation now michael taylor
down the line that's a fair ball this
will score gutierrez and the royals will
reclaim the lead
on michael taylor's double just his
third double on the year but you can get
the runner over and in with a hit like
that with a pool shot nicely done
change up
it stayed in the middle and he was on it
sped his bat up nice at bat again
taylor's starting to heat up because
he's seeing pitches
he's he's taking some pitches he's he's
that's how you get locked in
yeah that was really a quality of bat
when you consider he was down 0-2 and
the pitch he's swinging and he lines it
to center field but due makes the catch
taylor tags and badou just flips it back
into the infield and the royals have two
more in the fourth
and they lead 4-2
lucky to have watched him here's the 2-2
to ramos
and that's a bullet on the right side
for a baby's hit
second time he's been aboard here today
the 1-0
again rock and that is a fair ball
right on the chalk
ramos all the way to third akil badu
two for two he's got himself a double
here in the fifth
this is a sinker down and away it's
almost
the same spot he hit his first one
right on the line
third base
umpire sean barber right there to see it
and he can run so easily gets to second
base you can get him out though he's got
good stuff to get him out get him out
there you go really did get him out
on the strikeout pitch conviction right
there he knew he could get him out one
away for harold castro a couple of
ground outs for castro so far tonight
there it is right back up the middle
one run is home they're gonna hold badou
at third
they had to hold him but that little
bobble he probably would have made it
hitting harold castro
first pitch fastball
line drive right up the middle
line drive single makes it a 4-3 game
hitting harold that's all he does i said
he was in a slump when he hit two ground
balls to start the game
the appeal he went
and that is the second out
let's see did he go did he attempt to
swing at this
yes
here's the 2-2
swung on and missed big strikeout from
matthew boyd he punches out solaire for
the second time tonight and solaire are
unable to get that runner in from third
let's see if andrew benetendi can pick
him up
he rolls it up the middle and that's
going to drive in a run
just got it by the mound doing the
little things andrew benintendi
that's right second time
in this game that ben and tindy batting
behind solaire picked him up that's nice
we love that this game's all about
picking each other up
and ben and tindy short his swing he
just tried to put the ball in play and
hope that it found a hole and it did on
the infield great placement good touch
here's the pitch
carlos swings and it's a fly ball right
center field medium deep mazzara is
there he's got it lopez tags mazzara's
throw is way off line carlos santana
drives in his 29th
and the royals lead is 6-3 in the bottom
of the six
bases are loaded jamer candelario with
the plate
in there strike three call
candelario stays at home plate barking
at lance barrett
well there's there's no reason for him
to bark three and two that base is
loaded you better hack or he'll send you
back
he struck him out scott barlow with
back-to-back strikeouts of candelario
and cabrera to leave the bases loaded
and ben and tendy stole that base on
jimenez
by
about 10 steps hud
ball gets away andrew takes off for
third
now gutierrez can play a small ball try
and get him home from third base with
less than two out
[Music]
that'll score the run seven to three
royals gutierrez gets it done that's
right it's in his first run of the year
and that
is
going on contact wilson one for ford
today the 1-1
hammered to deep right field sounded
good that goes merrifield that ball is
crushed and gone
a two-run bomb from robbie grossman here
in the ninth
and the tigers have made it interesting
[Music]
yes they have because there's nobody out
and now they're one run away
two runs away excuse me
my math isn't good today i've had a few
mistakes
2-2 hammer to right in front of
merrifield
everybody advances one bag and the bases
are loaded with tigers here in the ninth
big big pitch 3-2 to scope here it is
strike three call
through a fastball starmont versus
castro
struck him out high anxiety at kauffman
stadium
but the royals get the victory